oggi ragazzi dei miei amici ci siamo
detti perché non andiamo al lago c'è
veramente ci siamo detti ieri allora
detto ok registro poi la mattina che
cosa significa per me registrare la
mattina significa questo parlano le mie
occhiaie in questo video io vado via
però possiamo cominciare per chi non lo
sapesse ragazzi di haier lover sarebbe
questo gioco dove devi io sono quello di
sfondo in tutto questo dove devi capire
chi è più famoso e chi no in questo caso
abbiamo saturno o torni d'arco che un
film che da quando ho visto un dormo più
penso saturno molto bene e di andare
avanti così e scegliere le cose che sono
più famose e le cose meno famose secondo
te mio record mondiale di questo gioco e
19 però vediamo se riusciamo a superarlo
ma non lo prendono credo almeno dieci
devo arrivare allora la mattina mi aiuta
donnie darko corinthians donnie darko
perfetto la partenza una mano dei ladri
bolo nome in sky nomen skype
mamma mia non erano mn sky verizon
secondo me i ragazzi a tutti quei 21
milioni
ci provo sei solo sei spesso molto di
più
verizon a carate verizon proprio lui
però ci sono la compagnia telefonica
americana perché io tutto qua carate o
mozart mozart mozart o pietro no a
scelte che way fi mistica wade secondo
voi ragazzi un sacco di gente cerca
c'hai miste che vuoi perché
meno meno ma pavia è andato benissimo
dragon trainer tra la sinistra che voi
dragon trainer dragon trainer veramente
fuoco cercato pensavo molto di più
dragon trainer e il padrino il padrino
perfetto del pallino e fifa 17 fifa 17
che grafica brutta forme che sono
arrivati 17 fifa 1 si vede anche poco la
pelata del guardalinee pica 17
immaginati quei 3 milioni ce li abbia
qua database qua nella testa il database
dei virus di avast è stato aggiornato
tutto qua tutto qua rapid eye movement
non so ma è dal settore ragazzi stiamo
andando e siamo a nove forse dieci ci
arriviamo eminem almeno un milione 4 ma
si eminem e va bene perfetto allora
adesso devo fare altri 10 per il record
mio record non lo so però bret hart meno
alarm clock di più un milione e due si
perché la gente si mette la sveglia
all'anno gioca i phone 7 i phone 7 mamma
mia ragazzi che treni che siamo sì che
bush tra chanel età i chicchi gazzetto
chanel ma lui non veste chan è al sicuro
dai chi e antoine che grib al n
beh credo crisman anche perché da dopo i
mondiali ma che ne so io
mamma mia che amano vari eventi mondiali
c'erano i realtà non si augurano i
mondiali alla francia una bestemmia per
lo stato italiano
cancelliamo l'ultima parte di video per
favore grazie tra antoine griezmann e
kiran che sarebbe il corano scritto non
lo so cosa vuol dire che io sono
ignorante ok sono ignorante meno vedi e
che essere ignorante non serva una sega
nella vita roa 16 sono micro anna guarda
a 16 ho perso per più grande li mortacci
mia rifacciamo la possiamo fare ragazzi
il reggae il record devo fare tra
povertà e maltese mamma mia la faccia
del maltese quante tenero maltese golf e
meno chi se ne frega del gol erano
uguali c'è la gente la gente che cerca
golf cerca maltese uguali tra golf e
terra
ma terra credo meno ma mi state
prendendo per il culo
lo spavento tu hai tanto è uguale acli
covo che voglio che in meno
porco demonio vedi che al 50 50 invece
faccio schifo allora abbiamo fatto
riscaldamento è il momento allora meno
che mai scritto
mia mamma se sbagli ti ammazzo ok tra
dragon trainer e zlatan ibrahimovic
penso che che zlatan sia dpa dalla zona
tancharoen almeno un milione nodi più un
milione e 700 così poco zlatan qualche
li picchia tutti sosa ma che venne una
giovane zlatan allora tra rose royce
quindi achille lauro e surfing credo
rolls royce esatto bene la partenza è
buona ragazza se confessa non so cosa
sia però va bene legato ad un'altra
gonfi one direction one direction
mammamia one direction come si sono
salvati in corner la one direction e
thor cornelius punk art of e credo one
direction kart offre non è ancora così
conosciuto però tra la ripristinato la
general election e valore non lo so
general election immagino sia a più alto
e ne frega nessuno nelle elezioni
demonio guarda se non vi in questo gioco
mi ammazzo tutti a zio ben e penso sia
una marca di peso sia il riso scotti
però dell'america a questo punto non
teniamocelo riso scotti e gruppo andro
con cio avra giusto quei 12 miliardi e
milioni 16 scusatemi jolo il di sminuito
ventola gruppone e quanto alle europee
groupon dai ragazzi a 20 leo arrivare me
ne vado di 4 gen marbles che genoa
marbles alex a chi e genna marbles come
genoa marble mi dispiace non ho ancora
avuto il piacere di fare le sue
colossale sap mi spieghi perché ti ho
comprata lo spieghi purtroppo non trovo
la risposta alla domanda che io neanche
io ragazzi un comprata alexa non serve a
niente niente non dice nulla
qualsiasi cosa ritieni non serve tra
genova argles e juventus
credo poi colpirlo che va bene juventus
2 milioni ce li avrà sette e mezzo tra
juve e le ass che bell'inglese ciò tra
place e verizon drive tra verizon e
daffy duck mi sono così sicuro che daffy
duck e si scriva tutti non dati
e invece no si scherzava comunque daffy
duck meno dislocata ancora la fidata
fila che santorini santorini coi due
milioni ce l'avrà dai uno solo uno meno
jeanne calment eurovision di più
ok ragazzi siamo a 10 incredibile
eurovisione leonardo da vinci leonardo
da vinci li chiamo questi 800 mila un
milione 2 va bene un'altra vice si vuol
meno seaworld qualche a marchio e di
rischio tema 12 raga sorveglianza di
massa meno che culo zaccaria nessuno
quando è così bassa ti sta praticamente
regalando anche quella dopo perde tempo
e impossibile che sia meno primo era
meno e faccia una figura incredibile la
oreo e transgender car 50 50 ragazzi non
so meno sporco demonio ero 14 vai
mamma mia ragazzi difficilissimo non
arriverò mai avente alexa mi devi dare
una mano ti prego questo potrebbe
rispondere alla tua domanda ma è una
cittadina e stimo lenze mie distretto di
dire il sotto distretto di veracruz ho
risposto alla tua domanda sia l'ex a
grazie tra undertaker e cocker spaniel
penso di più cocker spaniel mamma mia
oliver cromwell di meno madonna rose
royce di più sotto sono partiti da un
barca non è che non ci pensano di un
attimo pringles di più vai vai vai che
coltiviamo vai vai vai 13 e judo 13
judo e islam islam che dito storto
giusto quattro enti tuenti e leggo leggo
molto bene non ho idea di chi siano i
tutti del tuo thor cornelius panecutte
open tuenti totò cornelio reykjavik meno
10 south park di più un milione 8 c a
sul parquet youtube
il tutto come faccio a perdere io come
faccio per le barche kfc grazie del
gallo dietro che giustamente omegle kfc
non potete non prendere quello immagino
kfc abbia quei 13 milioni 55 spina
bifida tra spina bifida e charles darwin
chat a lui ne avrà un milioncino mamma
mi ha molto rischiato the office di più
va bene e siamo a todi cilag dai vespa
di meno ti prego di meno perfetto siamo
a quattordici ragazzi bayern monaco di
più
siamo a 15 chicca lascia di più siamo 16
credibile paragliding i meno madonna 17
di pigna non ti prego di veroli 18 siamo
primo rally legoli beach boys meno dai o
invogliate recco di l'ultima
ho avuto una mezza l'altre meno la vita
di cosa fosse miami dolphin di più e si
fa e si fa l'ho battuto l'ho battuto
l'ho battuto da shutout sound meno meno
mamma mia ragazzi arabi uniti più uguale
va bene va bene 23 del saie il silenzio
del ineos e degli innocenti di meno sono
una macchina verso incredibile singapore
di più guarda lo guardano come va
guardato 24 incredibile meno e cerca
ormai il re cornelli sto mangiando kata
tjuta meno ok che sembra milano quando
fa caldo dobermann di più ancor ben di
meno sono arrivato a 30 quasi raga 29
don chisciotte di più the prestige di
più il film grandissimo 31 black eyed
peas di più no è mai capito se ricorda
più nessuno
31 raga record
spero che vi sia piaciuto peccato che i
black eyed peas non è se non più così
ricercati che non fatti per capire cosa
che mi piace al momento mi piace anche
ai seguenti date tiziana cliccate il
tasto iscriviti anche la campanella per
rimanere aggiornati sul viso nuovo
uccidere i nuovi video e noi ci vediamo
come sempre a wroclaw fiorino belle
ragazze
[Musica]